a cyber security nightmare in 2022 the
number of cyber security attacks has
increased last year cryptocurrency hacks
alone brought in around 3.8 million
dollars for hackers we've gathered some
more shocking statistics for you
according to some reports
112.3 million attacks on iot devices
were carried out in 2022. over the year
the growth of attacks was 87 and what
about the fact that almost 200 000 new
mobile banking Trojans have appeared
this is 100 more than in 2021 the number
of attacks from hacking a PC for
cryptojacking to intrusion attempts has
reached 5.5 billion and the number of
ransomware viruses has increased by
almost 13 hackers also keep a close eye
on the Trends they created over 50 fake
apps posing as Chachi PT these
applications spread malicious programs
82 of all successful attacks were
related to the human factor including
social engineering errors and misuse
this means that people need to increase
their level of cyber literacy well our
Channel teaches cyber hygiene so
subscribe